bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs avec ce soir comme invité
laurent frayssinet bonsoir le rend moins
soirée loin alors l'actualité
internationale n'est pas très chargé en
ce moment il ya cependant un événement
et qui nous a un peu intéressé c'est le
match alexei shirov contre siemens
afghane stein donc alexei shirov on le
connaît il est numéro 4 mondial alors
que l'autre donc être einstein qui est
un joueur norvégien est moins connue
alors laurent je crois que tu le connais
un petit peu oui je connais un petit peu
je sais qu'il a été dans l'équipe de
norvège au football dont il a été prof
de professionnels de football ce qui est
assez impressionnant et il est dans les
100 meilleurs je sais pas s'il est enfin
en tout cas il était dans les cinq
meilleurs joueurs du monde pour les
déclamer d'ailleurs 111e
mais en tout cas c'est un très bon
joueur et il a donné beaucoup de fil à
retordre à l'écrit shirov oui alors ça
c'est sûr c'est à dire que le score
entre les deux joueurs avant le match
était de cinq et demi quatre et demi en
faveur d'élections
donc c'est un écart minimum et là ils se
sont affrontés donc en norvège dans le
match en semi rapide de quatre partis de
15 minutes par joueur et par parti
donc c'est des partis assez rapide et
donc à la grande surprise donc shirov
pas énorme favori est bien avec sa fille
rose perd la première partie violent
donc surprenant oui voilà mais comme
toujours avec son style avec son style
d'attac shirov a pris un peu trop de
risques et voilà il a perdu donc la
précision dans un match chacun deux
partis perdent la première est assez
embêtant c'est sûr alors mais d'autant
plus que bon einstein a un style très
très atypique très très curieux bon on
verra ça dans les les parties qu'on a
commenté on va commenter une en
intégralité peut-être un segment de la
suivante
en fait ils cherchent des ressources
tactique un peu curieuse dans toutes les
positions
alexei shirov aussi et ce qui est
bizarre c'est que il semblerait qu anne
cap chat est bien tiré son épingle du
jeu dans ce match
oui je crois que
il a beaucoup de talent c'est clair pour
être il a dû beaucoup trop il n'a pas dû
justement avoir beaucoup de temps pour
travailler les échecs et donc c'est vrai
que arriver à ce niveau là en étant de
joueur professionnel de football c'est
quand même assez impressionnant
oui c'est une double c'est la double vie
donc de si mais nadia chain est
clairement en tout cas bon là il s'est
un peu remis aux échecs face avant
puisque en l'an 2000 il a joué plus de
150 partis qui sont référencés dans la
base de données bon il y en a en tout
1000 ce qui fait quand même un joueur
qui a du métier qui a fait beaucoup de
compétition donc ça c'est important
voilà donc bref le match commence il
gagne la première est filmée la deuxième
donc ensuite on se demande qu'est ce qui
va se passer comment est ce que je suis
enfin prévu de remonter dans ce match
parce que il suffit d'une nulle de
galles shane pour déjà réalisé un an la
moitié d'un exploit parce que match nul
contre oshiro il m'a tenu le coup de
chance c'est honnête même demi heure et
demie c'est un score tout à fait
honorable mais ça ils avaient déjà après
deux parties il peut pas il y aura des
accords généraux au début au début du
match si on les dit qu'il va faire qui
va perdre deux ennemis un ennemi konture
bon il n'y a pas à rougir
alors bon c'est vrai que
psychologiquement on peut se demander
dans quel état il était est ce que son
but dans ce match était de ne pas être
ridicule ou bien de gagner le match on a
une semaine chez son jeune élève
moi j'ai joué j'ai joué justement phase
aller que c'est chiant fait michael
adams ont deux matches difficiles
je crois que la première chose déjà on
essaie de ne pas être ridicule et après
bon si on peut faire quelque chose en
essais mais le plus important en avoir
quand on arrive dans ce genre de match
c'est de ne pas être ridicule
ca c c'est la foi c'est la première
chose qu'on se dit il faut vraiment
c'est quand même assez important et
après bon au fil de la partie on
s'aperçoit finalement bon les gars il ya
une différence de niveau c'est clair
mais que sait pas si grand le fossé est
pas et pas si énorme et que on a on a
une chance et là c'est la preuve que
finalement un joueur qui a auto aux
alentours de la 100e place mondiale face
à alexei shirov qui numéro quatre
mondial
bon il perd mais bon sans plus disons
que la surprise était clairement
envisageable clairement possible a noté
quand même alors j'ai donc j'ai perdu le
fil mais c'est pas grave
donc ouais bah non je sais vraiment plus
donc on va je pense qu'on va commenter
la partie donc c'est la troisième partie
du match il n'y a pas grand chose à dire
sur le score dans la mesure où at
capitaine donc a finalement perdu le
match
classe non alexei shirov premier avec de
poids ni est 2e avec un point et demi
tout de suite on va passer laurent à la
partie commenté donc on a dû choisi de
commenter la troisième du match
c'est la plus tendue dans la mesure où
adrian donc s'y fait nul réalise déjà
l'exploit donc il a les pièces blanches
il peut jouer solide mais on va voir ce
qui s'est passé dès que l'échiquier sera
arrivé voilà il est là donc nous allons
commencer à john shen blanchir of noir
ils jouent des quatre des cinq ces
carrières tout et c6
tu veux dire trois cavaliers phcie saint
laurent je crois que tu es un peu un
spécialiste quand même de cette
ouverture puisque tu joues beaucoup de
slave semi slave
donc c'est en fait la slave cc 2 enfin
cette femme intervention assez solides
chez lui c'est vrai que j'ai joué ça
j'ai joué ça depuis que je suis depuis
j'ai l'impression d'avoir commencé à
jouer aux échecs en jouant cette source
sûre c'est que ça fait très longtemps
que je joue ça je sais même plus de
piles ça va faire depuis l'âge de 11 12
ans que je loue cette ouverture en
anglais c'est vrai que mais j'aime
beaucoup c'est vrai que c'est c'est à la
fois solide et à l'afrique
ça peut créer des contre chance donc
c'est assez et c'est très bien et je
conseille à tous les jeunes joueurs de
cette ouverture
alors bon mais enfin l'inconvénient
quand même de cette ouverture laurence
est clair c'est que la position va
rester très calme n'y aura pas
spécialement de complications c'est
plutôt un jeu de contres ou les noirs
subissent quand même la pression des
blancs oui enfin il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de complication quand on regarde nos
me boude vinik par exemple oui il peut y
avoir des complications quand même c'est
c'est un jeu positionner reald fois
shirov quant au regard des partitions
sur la semi slave
on se dit que finalement c'est peut-être
aussi une ouverture compliqué oui c'est
vrai que si rosemont est connu pour
réussir à mettre le feu au lac c'est à
des positions très tranquille très calme
tu parlais du grand baie de botnie nick
laurent alors le groupe bodine hic c'est
qu'on
donc blanc qui est sûre la casse t1
vient sur la 4g 5 pas tout de suite mais
enfin tout de suite c'est jouable
également la jiansheng choisi une vente
plus modérée voilà bon le un des coups
critiques c'est comme le coup cavaliers
c3 qui aurait été ce coup là qui laisse
donc l'option ces quatre ans prises
momentanément les noirs peuvent le
prendre et là on est dans la pure slave
donc les noirs c'est le sang donne un
pion obtiennent des compensations et
c'est tout à fait jouable ici elles
gagnent stein choisi le couple 3 qui
al'avantage de défendre directement sur
ces quatre et qui a l'inconvénient de
boucher le fossé est donc c'est pour ça
justement que beaucoup de grands joueurs
dont kaspar enfants ont donné leur
opinion sur ce coup là et on dit que il
pensait pas que c'était disons que s'ils
ont cherché la vérité aux échecs on
devait sortir sont fous de cases noires
pour essayer de gagner mais bon c'est
vrai qu'on peut pas toujours le faire et
que il pense pas que ce que par exemple
kasparov pense qu'avec et après 2-3 les
blancs d'oeufs n'obtiennent pas
davantage donc cette formation sont
inoffensives
donc toi quand on joue à trois mois
lancé tout de suite en non c'est une
partie mais disons que si on est à la
recherche de la vérité
cc c'est clair que fout g5 doit être
disant que si un jour là ce missile
avait réfuté ça sera avec fu g5
donc ça c'est un avis disons
philosophique parce que yao a priori
aucune raison que
que ce soit fouge est simple plutôt que
trois qui soit le meilleur coup bas si
si le fou en faire mais maintenant on
est enfermé donc c'est la raison donc
débat d'ouverture a ajouté c ghosn comme
très solide c'est à dire qu'avec les
noirs ça devient mais voilà c'est
l'héroïne dernier a gagné quand c'est le
problème c'est pas très agressif donc ça
peut être ils ont que ça peut pas être
disons fou g5 et certainement un
meilleur coup mais bon c'est signe
partie cette chute par c'est tout à fait
jouable
là les noirs peuvent jouer le coup
hausse est aussi celle ci c'est une
petite faute déjà une petite faute un
petit fait d'accord donc le bon coup
théoriquement cette société si des gens
il y a il ya beaucoup de problèmes
après fou détroit et maintenant
l'avantagent fou détroit le coût normal
et cavaliers c3 à la place de foot et
trompeuse retail ses trois médailles
disons qu'on sait pas où va aller le
cavalier blanc oui le cavalier b1 donc
il peut aller en d2 oui ou en c3 et
singles et noir ont du mal à s'organiser
contre ça et donc ses seins petits seins
petits neurones de coups une petite
subtilité à connaître d'accord donc
quand on joue à trois on a une vie plus
ou moins aussi c'était aussi ce qui est
donc la seule miss lave moins percutant
voilà à cause de fous des trois quilles
où les blancs d'oeufs vient de l'autre
possibilité est assis sous son passif à
6 intéressant je crois que morose et
vite j'avais dû jouer ça contre kasparov
non quelque chose de similaire contre
oui c'est possible
c'est fou et 5 donc là ça c'est le coup
recommandé dans la logique quand on sort
on sort notre fou avant justement de
l'enfermer en général l'inconvénient
d'avoir sorti s'en fout trop vite c'est
que l'option b 7 se retrouve en prison
voilà tout ça permet aux blancs de jouer
des coups comme dame b 3 bon donc ici
adventure choisi food et 3 ici il est
très tranquille semnan qu'une chaîne
puisqu'il sait que la nul lui suffit
donc pour faire au moins match nul si ce
n'est mieux c'est-à-dire mener 2-1 au
score avec une partie restante donc à
genk a été clairement cours
en tout cas faire nul dans cette errance
et quand on joue trop pour faire nul en
général c'est le revers de la médaille
voilà alors ici donc quand on a préparé
un petit peu cette partie laurent tu
m'as dit fou j'ai si c'est plus fort
qu'eux fou prend fou je sais pas moi
j'ai un nom un choix j'ai étudié les
parties karpov et kasparov et je sais
que il ya eu beaucoup de poser deux
parties comme ça qu'a sport en fait
toujours jouer foulée 6 et n'a jamais eu
aucun problème est souvent et jouer pour
le gain donc moi je préfère fuji 6
personnellement alors à noter quand même
que kasparov joue souvent pour le gain
enfin oui d'accord mais je pense qu au
fuji si toute façon et meilleure ou
d'accords bon issifou prend des trois a
été choisie dame prend fou maintenant
aussi ce donc là d'une si on raisonne
d'une façon simple a priori la pression
devrait être équilibré puisque les
blancs ou un fou a priori moins bon que
le food et noir puisque le fond blanc et
sur la même couleur que ces produits on
nous vend sa marque le fou noir n'ont en
revanche les dons un petit avantage
puisqu'ils ont pu en c4 qui met une
pression sur le centre noire cean tâche
des espaces voilà donc les charentais
l'espace donc c'est une pression à
double tranchant les blancs font petit
rock et noir je cavale et b17 gallois il
y avait un spécialiste de cette position
s'était mirail botulinique donc champion
du monde d'échecs pendant très longtemps
qui jouait systématiquement le coup qui
avait dit b d2 alors ça paraît curieux
quand même ça court et pourtant l'idée
est simple c'est de jouer le coup de
trois ou quatre très vite les noirs vont
être obligés de prendre on reprendra
alors avec lecavalier et ensuite le
phocéen va sortir sur la case les 5
donc ça c'est l'idée des blancs une des
idées dans cette pression s'est joué le
coup à 3,4 et là il a choisi de mettre
le cadet en c3 adventure choix à ses
responsables puisqu'après fouquet 4 1
eh ben on a du mal à jouer à 4 oui tout
à fait donc il s'est pas moqué vidéo
c'est intéressant pour jouer aux quatre
mais cinq ça fait une petite faiblesse
en niqab qui nous a fait des pions bah
je sais pas moi j'aime pas trop mais bon
je sais de toute façon j'aime pas la
position des blancs donc d'accord déjà
j'ai déjà ma vie est fait alors j'aime
pas le concept on va avancer un petit
peu dans cette partie de rang puisque
les complications vont arriver food et 2
les deux donc on sort le fou l'idée
c'est de provenant de reprendre en c3
avec le fou si jamais ça se présentait
donc de jouer en toute logique alors la
lune on peut jouer petit rock mais ne
joue pas il préfère jouer à cinq escales
une explication logique et rationnel
c'est ce que tu m'as dit tout à l'heure
qui prenait 5 mois ah oui oui c'est vrai
c'est toi qui est unanimement exemple
les sept qui soit un petit rock c'est un
coût possible
on aurait pu avoir envie de jouer mais
là il ya une petite pointe tactique
assez intéressante et intrigante c'est
le couple qui avait demandé cinq qui
sort de nulle part alors l'idée est
simple si les noirs je fous l'camp fous
ont fait cavaliers prend cavaliers et
chaque au roi voilà on va regarder les
ventes
cheikh les noirs prennent maintenant on
reprend des deux villes en matériel les
blancs ont pitié un pion petite attaque
éclaire donc ils vont apprendre plus
donc une position proche du lien
technique voilà et après calais prend
des cinq autres possibilités
donc si on reprend le cavalier
directement avec le pion est bien
souvent la série blanc kilos fu
oui et donc il ya toujours une fois de
plus dernière possibilité cavaliers
procure des cinq puis on prend les cinq
ans tu apprends qu'il y ait donc là mais
maintenant les voilà le fou et attaquer
donc fausse
il faut que fo prend feu et dames n'en
joue si on prend aussi ses
intermédiaires
j'en prends aussi c'est donc est ce
qu'il va se passer il ya deux pièces
attaquer donc les noirs ont une pièce de
plus mais les blancs attaque deux pièces
donc le fouet le cavalier les noirs
peuvent pas déformer 2 par exemple si je
fou prend le soin continuer à mettre
deux pièces emprise
oui mais on joue plus on prend avec cet
échec pour preuve cet échec voilà et on
est tous contre 7 tours prend et ensuite
entièrement aux trois avec les gens un
pion de plus en plus donc ici il ya déjà
eu un petit piège quand même
c'est que après fou des deux ont menacé
entre guillemets de jury qui avait dix
points au cours des 5 1 pour schirrhein
petit oui c'est un piège c'est voilà
effectivement c'est un piège pas
vraiment pour shirov il par la menace
facilement défendant s'en fout en jouant
le cou à cette a5 qui en plus est un bon
coup
disons que l'idée maintenant c'est sûr à
3 par exemple s'il est si les blancs
font 1,3 trop vite peut-être qu'on
pourra jouer quelque chose comme fou
prend ces trois faux procès 3 4 10 ans
et l'idée peut-être ça peut être de
pousser les pions de c'est d'essayer de
fixer alors là c'est parce que justement
une invasion oui parce qu'après france
et 3 français 3 le coup à cinq à quatre
on a effectivement envie de le jouer
pour fixer les pions mais là peut-être
fou les quatre simples et voilà c'est le
problème mais plus tard je sais pas je
dis ça pas tout de suite c'est pour plus
tard
d'accord donc dans sa position à 3 n'a
pas été jouer donc justement 1,3 ça peut
être un peu haut pour montrer à trois ça
peut être un coup intéressant
voilà donc on va le revoir fou 7.7 nous
font revient et maintenant le piège le
piège classique le piège classique donc
qui est aux 80 donc ça c'est un coup que
effectivement que les blancs ont envie
de jouer puisqu'il met une pression
énorme sur le centre des noirs ici
ils menacent de jouer aux 85 donc
d'avancer encore leurs pions en principe
les noirs sont obligés de prendre
on reprend un peu cavalier ont fait des
échanges sans trop et on a gagné la
possession du centre bell je crois qu'il
ya un petit problème il ya un petit
problème est justement dans cette
position je crois que ça marche pas
notre petit problème
d'accord donc c'est très compliqué bon
maintenant cavalier c5
c'est une thématique faut toujours
regarder c'est alors qu'elle et ses cinq
coups thématique laurence c'est curieux
lecavalier est en prise donc c'est bon
c'est vraiment surprenant cette heure
que ce genre de piège faut connaître aux
courses et ses jets de pierre ont
célébré jeudi l'espace est donc
maintenant qu on prend ces 5 mai ils
seront frais ça marcherait ans est
retrouvé sur le dos on va voir pourquoi
puis on prend le 4 oui et maintenant on
s'aperçoit que donc la whey on va on va
détailler un petit peu le on attaque la
la dame et de cavaliers et en même temps
la dame attaque la dame voilà donc si
l'ademe bouge c'est n'importe où
voilà rend le câblier simplement si la
dame blanche bien sûr
une case qu'elle est disponible dans les
cases pointé en rouge ici on va
reprendre ce cavalier avec égalité
matérielle mais les noirs auront une
meilleure structure de coûts voilà donc
d'un problème d'un programme pour
prendre un tour programme est là qu'est
ce qu'on voit là on a l'impression est
là maintenant cavalier prend pions alors
bon on va on va encore expliqué parce
que l'accent continue et on a toujours
une pièce de - laurent dans cette
position la tour cependant attaque le
food et deux oui le pion aux quatre
attaques le cavadee f3 donc ça c'est
tout problème c'est tout problème des
blancs en ce moment puisque s'il qui
valait 3 bougez le fou des données
perdues
et si le foot est debout gbl qui veut
dire 3 a perdu donc on a une pièce de
moins mais on va probablement la
récupérer donc voila et maintenant
cavalier prendre quatre cas les
professions cahier prend pions quel
écran qu'il va lier deux cas les banques
à venir pendant et la france y en a cinq
et c'est pour ça que ça marche pas dans
cette position d'agglomérât piétons à
retourner en arrière alors où l'on
explique donc en fait c'est retenez bien
ce qu'il vient de se passer c'est que en
toute fin de variantes via un pion
quitterait le pion à se bat il se trouve
je m'arrête je m'appelais plus
exactement deux ans des coûts donc non
c'est dans cette position
voilà dont 4 à 3 fawcett fawcett
alors maintenant aux 4 n'est pas jouable
ici à cause de pions prend le 4 si on
prend le cas donc ça c'est la véritable
refondation du coup aux quatre voilà ça
c'est pas mon coup mais quand cavaliers
prend le quart kerry pendant quatre
maintenant 1,4 ou cavaliers prend le 4 à
4 d'accord voilà donc ici c'est
positionnelle tout semble donc voilà
c'est positionnelle mais maintenant le
coup joué par les blancs dans la partie
dans la première partie où ce piège a
été c'est une partie des risques et je
m'appelle les blancs on joue et on peut
montrer notre opposition non avant avant
d'accord la main en fait pour empêcher
justement ce couleurs ils ont joué une
b3 isme b3 dans cette position voilà
donc petit rentrer d'accord donc là on
arrive vraiment sur le piège peut-être
de 4 c'est la partie c'est la première
partie qui a vu ce pitch casing
maintenant qu'ils essaient 500 go pour
respectivement financer cinq pions tron
gens qui reprend les quatre dames prend
des huit donc programmes et leurs dons
et greffes
on est reprendre et vite et voilà on y
est allés prendre un avion cavaliers
préemption une pure 1,5 et plus en prise
et le pion c5 va tomber tout de suite
d'accord et donc on va gagner sur ses
cinq donc
donc voilà donc un piège thématiques il
faut faire très attention
faut vérifier si mr chow si on peut
reprendre de la tour f ou pas il faut
toujours vérifier donc ici à 3 n'a pas
été jouer donc à cause de photos cette
expression tout à fait tranquille tout à
fait jouable
elle gagne celle là commence une m1 peut
s'emballer il joue le coup c4 c5 qui en
principe est une faute positionnelle
puisque ça laisse le champ libre aux
noirs au centre
c'est dire que le cou aux cinq qui est
donc un peu libératoire quand même pour
les noirs libérateur même si tu veux ça
donc aussi soit 5 solide avec la menace
au 5e quatre gagnants de l'espace et à
l'envers une attaque de maths sur le roi
blanc et s'éclaircit le noir il va faire
un 4 e mail se passer mais bon c'est
sais pas s'il faisait quand même c'est
pas si facile
alors bon l'avantagé de ce coup le
dernier coup de fouet par les blancs
pendant c'est que le fou ici il va donc
ne reviendra plus jamais en recettes à
priori donc on va pouvoir jouer en fait
le pari des blancs et et que l dame ils
sont gagnants c'est clair ils vont jouer
avec beckett dessin qui vont échanger le
fou l'album c'est la partie de gauche de
l'échiquier
donc voilà la partie gauche de chéquiers
dix ans ils vont faire ils vont créer
une rupture en bessin qu'avec le pion
donc en fait ouais là pour servir de
fonds ils vont pousser nord de pions
voilà ils vont échanger le pion à voile
à hope so s'échanger des céans b5 le
pion mais les chercheurs c'est cissé y
aura une faiblesse en c6 veut avancer et
en général dans ce type de position les
blancs sont mieux mais bon le problème
c'est qu'ils sont très malins
donc c'est l'un des contrôles à loin
d'accord dont contre correctionne
dynamique voilà une course le plus
rapide va façon géniale a donc d'une en
fait on se demande si elles savent jouer
vraiment je le vraiment pour faire de la
vraie puisque c'est très tendu il aurait
pu échanger des pièces ne rien faire et
probablement faire nul mais là il
commence et il va lui même se jeter dans
la gueule du loup enfin en tout cas
provoquer des complications c'est
d'enfin mais bon c'est vrai que s'il
gagne 2,2 me 0,1 micron shirov c'est
beau ça va peut-être 11
moi je sais pas ça jamais arrivé alors
comme ça mais peut-être qu'on se voit
beau après
on commence à y croire on ne le sait pas
après ces cinq chirurgies petit rock il
faut sortir ces pièces
et là coup intéressant le coup cavaliers
à 4 voilà c'est pas mal c'est l'idée
c'est que le fou était pas très bon donc
on a envie on préfère garder notre
cavalier donc c'était dans la position
précédente si on joue le coup à trois il
ya bien entendu la fameuse séquence
quand vous avez déjà expliqué ding la
menace c'est très mauvais français 3
supposons qu'on reprenne du fou je pense
qu'on joue mieux en jeu à quatre on joue
à quatre
quand je vois faire savoir donc on casse
l'initiative des blancs côté gauche de
l'échiquier puisqu'il ya toujours cette
fameuse prise en passant qui va casser
la structure des blancs donc après petit
rock cavalia quatre coins terrassant qui
avait dit aux 4 alexei shirov on le sent
assez normal et matin donc bon ben là à
3 à 3 ou 4 ans voilà c'est normal pour
jouer des quatre plus tard pour pour
essayer de gagner cette bataille al-dam
justement le plus rapidement possible
c'est sa taille et en plus c'est un coût
qui a une double utilité donc c'est bien
c'est bon c'est normal c'est dans
l'esprit fo prend fou cavaliers prend on
menace au jockey et au cavalier
gagnantes sont les noirs peuvent prendre
ils ne font pas ils préfèrent un coup un
peu atypique mais non enfin probablement
de très thématiques dans cette position
mais qui surprend toujours
c'est dans l'esprit de toute façon
shirov sait très bien qu elle m dames si
latin il va perdre les dames donc il
faut qu'ils aient attaqué le roi et donc
f5
voilà c'est ça permet de passer
probablement la tour f 6 où le cavalier
enfin ça permet de faire pas mal de
choses
f5 donc permet effectivement d'amener la
tour en jeu donc là c'est une attaque
directe qui se profile sur le roi blanc
la dame qui passe peut-être sur la 4g 5
éventuellement le coup au 6 e 5 toujours
là donc en fait on essaie de stabiliser
la case aux quatre provoquer les blancs
à jouer f3 qui sera affaiblissant pour
le roi ou alors simplement on a mis
notre cavalier puis on va le tenir en 4
pendant très longtemps donc là
effectivement il est hors de question
pour les blancs de prendre ça serait une
faute positionnelle
assez grave on reprend du pied bref la
dame doit bouger pourraient fondre les
noirs ont ouvert la tour c au sein vont
passer leur pièce très belle position
d'attaqué ici pour les noirs alors que
les blancs sont complètement excentré
après f5 f3 là il ya un choix quand même
soit on prend des deux soit on prend pas
mais je j'ai un peu de mal à expliquer
le choix de shirov d'ailleurs dans cette
position qui décide de repartir en grève
si je crois que quand on lance une
attaque contre le roi mais c'est
peut-être une généralité je vais venir
mais bon plus on a deux pièces en plus
les plus belles chances de maths et donc
en plus avec deux cavaliers c'est pas
mal moins moche en effet pas j'aime bien
mes cavaliers
non mais bon toute façon faut garder le
maximum de pièces si on veut mater dans
c'était un style de boudin ce type de
position avec même s'il attaque avec
saddam sa tour et son cavalier et
il vas y vas jamais réussir à mater mais
quand donc en fait il faut garder un
maximum de pièces c'est clair quand on
veut attaquer on garde des pièces
regarder défier s'attaque donc à un
suicide que vous pouvez appliquer
effectivement quand vous voulez attaquer
droit de votre adversaire est bien à
l'échangé fans pièce effectivement bonne
stratégie surtout que 40 cavaliers d2 le
cavalier d2 ce qu'on peut voir c'est
qu'il va pas forcément servir défendre
mais qui a plutôt aller sur le côté
gauche de l'échiquier donc mesdames
essayer de prendre notre dame toute
façon chez en fils a perdu les hommes
donc bon faut pas qu'il la perde trop
vite évidemment parce que sinon il
perdra partie mais bon c'est pas grave
donc là qu'il va lire va pas elle va pas
empêcher l'asnl a de l'attak l'attaquent
noir c'est parti là donc pour la fameuse
légère parce qu'à ce jeu course je pense
pas que l'ailé nord samedi qui je pense
est dans cette pression doit et
équilibrée pour transformer blanc je
sais pas j'aime bien les blancs mais bon
je pense que j'ai enfin jouer trop
fichiers pas bay 4-1 c'est l'heure si on
prend les captures prend b4 et il m'a
l'air un peu en retard nains cours
justement les iem dessin qui arrive en
un coût et il n'a pas il n'est pas trop
il est la pièce la donc une nouvelle
généralités quand même pour contredire
un peu ce que tu es en train de dire
c'est que quand on attaque sur le roy on
va mater alors que la sur la dame qu'est
ce qui à prendre finalement juste un
pion donc une quinzaine de conférences
payant il ya tout qui est ou qui saute
on contourne voilà en comptant le temps
l'adversaire à prendre mais club d'amos
est donc avec ses chiens vous jouez au 5
et éventuellement là c'est là c'est
peut-être une erreur qui l'a fait cai b3
je pense aussi au f4 ou papa f4 oui ça
c'est laisser le effectivement c'est la
grosse question dans cette position ex
cat chow et les blancs ajourés fillatre
un f4 sa ferme complètement le jeu f4 et
b5 après et puis ça va être dur et puis
avec dreyer pour les cinq la tâche je
pense que c'est vraiment tout simplement
je pense que c'est je suis pas je sais
pas comment c'est dur à juger mais ils
ont moria g5 qui va arriver évidemment
un cavalier ou 4g simple quelque chose
comme ça mais non encore des plans mais
ça a l'air moins percutant ok ça doit
être à peu près clément et je pense
quand même parce que les noirs sont
quand même en mars source position donc
complexe difficile
de donner des variantes simple puisque
c'est quand même c'est vrai que c'est
une course c'est pas évident évalué en
tout cas qu'ils avaient trois c'est un
coût qui a l'air un petit peu méprisant
pour la taïga noir voilà puisque on
déporte une pièce on va complètement de
l'autre côté on lui dit bah écoute vas-y
attaque moi c'est exactement ça ce qui
est en train de faire le joueur
norvégien shirov il relève le défi de 5
là on voit ça y est les pions noirs
commencé à avancer c'est une sorte de
rouleau compresseur qui arrive
cavalli à 5 voilà donc oui monarde il va
protection mais c est il a piqué lui
enlever sa taille mais ça c'est sûr une
fois qu'on prend 2,7 après on peut
envisager de revenir à 5 et d'aller
contre ces six voilà pourquoi pas même
de d'alerté 6 a une belle caisse en d6
bien vu c'est vrai que c'est un bond de
20 15 en réussissant plus qui contourne
qui quand on aime bien qu'il revienne
bien mais qui en revient bien sûr et le
roi donc c'est pas mal quand on investit
son contrôle des très belles qualités
notamment la case f5 la case aux quatre
c'est important mais alexei shirov joue
au 5e cartonnant paye sacrifier les dons
qu'ils y croient et noël celis est le
fuit pas encore c'est puisque quatre
s'attaque la dame pour lui en fait de ne
pas donner mon accord à la pression
prend 1,4 là ils sacrifient vraiment
puisqu'il reprend avec le cavalier donc
n'attaquant plus la dame le pion de 7 se
retrouve donc en prise à noter qu'il
aurait pu reprendre avec le pion à être
par exemple
oui mais disons en attaque les terrains
entier préserve de ce qu'est l'air
d'être un coût plus naturel a priori
enfin non en fait non d'ailleurs non pas
du tout dames 2 et là effectivement il
ne voit pas le cas des six peut pas
sortir donc la dame lesdain cela la
tournée puis cela s'est terminé
je pense que depuis il est même pas
envisagée dans les dixièmes de seconde
son cavalier 38,4 sacrifice du pion 17
pointé en rouge
on a mis quand même un bouquet vallier
henri iv voilà il ya l'autre ce qui va
venir
c'est comme ça et c'est l'intérêt non
mais ça doit se passer l'austro keolis
est l'intérêt d'avoir d'avoir gardé une
cabine on sait jamais ça peut toujours
servir de chaînes d'avoir gardé
d'accabler veulent mieux qu'en 2007
quels défis surtout que quand on regarde
quand on regarde bombe le cavalier de d2
est allé enlever cette crème aimer
l'autre cavaliers à 4 oui oui
restez là un peu trop longtemps
peut-être faut c'est sur ces énormes tas
savané mais sinon c'est fini à 5 donc on
revient pour prendre encore un pion un
pion on sait si c'est assez logique
shirov lui alors oui ça y est de toute
façon là il a complètement abandonné la
dame
il va écoute tous les pions sont à toi
sers toi moi je m'en fous je mets mes
deux cavaliers en le 4g 4 maintenant je
passe la dame
s'il le faut je ramène encore la tour et
je joue mon va tout simplement je fonce
dans cette position donc là alors plus
un parti quinze minutes à 0 l'un en
règle pour le web ça doit être assez
terrible on se surprend de l'attak comme
ça qui arrive au lavoir y aller moi il a
cherché quand même une vérité non je ne
sais pas il a été clair qu'il a cherché
donc en plus quand shirov il faut payer
deux fois
faut pas dire deux fois shirov qui a de
la tacc donc là y'a qu'à y penser si ce
qui était possible mais qui perd de
manière quasi forcée
donc on peut on peut montrer un look et
36 après damas 4 il ya une attaque de
maths
h3 regardez bien cette position on va
l'avoir par transposition de la partie
normale projet transposition c'est un
ordre de coups différents qui aboutit à
la même position
donc dans la partie il a joué h3 et du
damage théâtre cet office de pièce la
durée pu voir qu'il est prend ses six
encore bloqués il faut aussi si je pense
briquet processus sa terre en ligne
enfin ça coup quand même qu'on a envie
de jouer pour plusieurs raisons ça
permet toujours l'échec henry cette rame
à 71,5 y revenir en f4 saleuses est une
belle classe de défense est fourni en
l'occurrence oui donc ça ne menace pas
les chefs commence à menacer peut-être
de jeunes cavaliers aux cinq échangeant
des pièces enfin ça remet les pièces en
jeu mais là il ya un gain
terrible et foudroyant le cavalier e qui
vient en relève deux attaques la dame la
dame doit bouger
par exemple en d2 ou en deux mois je
préfère un mois ou deux de toute façon
c'est pareil il ya d'alger trois menaces
matt qui ici donc est tout simplement
imparables ou alors trop des victoires
même de dinde à mach 2 puisque
apprécions pranger 4 on reprend avec
lecavalier et donc c'est dommage de aida
machin mat
donc on voit que shirov donc à donner
une pièce il ya cette fine place vers le
roi et demi a donné tous ses pions à
gauche et avec dame et cavaliers ils
arrivent à mater donc il ya des
variantes comme ça qu'il commence à
devenir assez significatif que les noirs
est vraiment dû contre grillage part ça
c'est fini
ces avantages d'ici venons ici il a trop
joué
il en a trop fait alors bon autres coups
qu'on a en autre question qu'on se pose
dans cette position donc on rappelle
qu'à l'extérieur vient de jouer
damages 4 pourquoi on ne prend pas le
cavalier sas everest gaming par une
pièce d'attac
ça c'est une question qu'on peut se
poser à nouveau pu reprendre chez 4
simplement surprend g4 donc ça ouvre la
colonne f
ça permet encore d'échanger déplacer à
melesse surtout g3 savane g 3g 3 suivi
de damages de maintenant et c'est
imparable c'est salaires par salaires
imparable bon peut-être tour f4 quand
même pour clouer le pion oui donc on
prend 1,4 on prend un f4 j'en prends
donc je crois que tu connais mon coup de
maître de chaque année on chez 3g 3g 3
suivi de passage de la dame ici ils en
soient ici c'est la touraine qui
traînent bruce wayne et il surtout la
menace est la grosse menace et kf2 avec
des machins matt keough edf doit aussi
machin est donc là c'est en fait c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe dans cette
version parce qu'on voit les deux qu'ils
avaient les blancs tu en as 5 et a4 sont
complètement spectateurs qui ne font
rien du tout qui sont là vraiment
un peu par hasard ils ont ils ont pas
ils ont accompli la moitié de leurs
missions aux maliens c'est à dire qu'ils
ont pris un pion mais c'est tout ils
sont pas créé de menaces renault a gagné
le dernier the way dont ils ont gagné à
une dame
mais c'est pas suffisant passez vite
d'un match 4 donc la jiansheng trouve un
coussin pas de défense tour f3 je crois
que c'est plutôt du désespoir non du
désespoir ils empêchent la zaouïa au
niger est il obligé en g3 peut-être que
le 1 des coûts intéressants mentionné
enfin trouvé à l'analyse un pouce et
déco complexe c'est le coutour à 2 oui
c'est laisser des notes conclut notre
quotidien qui prévient donc le cavalier
noir devenir en f2 c'est vrai que ça va
l'empêcher de venir puisqu'il ya une
tour de plus qui va défendre la case en
plus on défend j'ai deux danses armand
fin tour à deux c'était un bon coup de
défense mais le trouver en quinze
minutes c'est très difficile parce que
c'est vrai que laurence et du cnra tour
à deux têtes je pense que c'est pas 62 g
iii peut-être on peut même jouer d'alger
trois dames g3 n'ayant projet cap
torikian projet 4 c'est chaud alors on
va juste mentionné puisque la liasse que
c'est très bien y a quand même montré
des ressources pour rallier son d'alger
3 est en projet de 400 projets de 4,5
l'idée d'un mach 4 août où reprend f1 et
touré fuite je sais pas damage 4g 3
traduire en empêcher enfin je sais pas
si ça marche maman il ya peut-être une
idée aussi à kg cinq cavaliers h3 ou
kayak 3 je sais pas enfin il ya beaucoup
de il ya une initiative qui semble assez
considérable aux eris c'est vrai qu'on
n'aimerait pas avoir les blancs dans
cette position contre un joueur comme
cheer up mais ça va se faire pas
spécialement confiance donc il a joué
tout reste trois cavaliers g5 à noter
quand même que pour l'instant les noirs
même s'ils ont beaucoup de cas sont
prises ils ont finalement qu'un
changement pour lens pour l'instant rien
des regards et blanchir le nom entre les
dents arrivent à leur terme a-2 cavadee
première fois qu'il est pro tour et ça
c'est logique donc là c'est pas encore
très graves si elle est s'il arrive à
part une seule qualité les les blancs
c'est ça y est ils en ligne aile dame
dont ils sont comme rossi a donné leur
tour - en 2e tour mais ils ont éliminé
le cavalier qui était 1,4 très très
méchant mais donc c'est un sacrifice de
qualité positionnelle qu'elle les prend
tous dame prend donc là on peut se dire
ça y est les blancs ont réussi à tenir
maintenant ils vont manger à ses 6 ou
alors jouer qu'avec des six potasse à
regret ou pousser leurs pions b
maintenant ça va jouer à la dame mais
c'est jacques chirac dit non non la tacc
continuer dans cette position donc tout
va vite
joli coup d'attac cavaliers fonction c6
c'est vrai que vie si c'est ça commence
est délicate composé défense puisque il
apte à continuer les pieds en pieds en
fait la plus en plus de pièces à
l'attaqué on peut toujours pas reprendre
angers 4 puisque c'est le pion f qui
reprend et qui est apprécié et 3 avec g3
qui vient et c'est le mat force est donc
ici monkey & trans et 6 contre attaques
quand même champion des cinq noter que
les blancs c'est vrai que s'il arrive à
ne pas se faire mater il faut pas qu'ils
vont s'installer faut pas que les noirs
faux pas il faut pas qu'ils leur crainte
c'est clair il faut qu'ils jouent des
coups précis jusqu'à la fin c'est vrai
qu'il est mentionné lmnp si on inverse
les adversaires c'est donc si on dit
c'est shirov qui a les blancs et la
deuxième chaîne qui allaient noir est
toujours un effet psychologique qui joue
comme ça alors on sait qu'on se dit
qu'on va shirov a tout vu ça y est ils
piquent les pions et on est pas mal mais
je pense que non il ya une part de
subjectivité
non je pense que les noirs toute façon
qu'est-ce qui est rien je vais te
reprend 1,3 sillage la tour points 3
balles dont trois d'un prend des cinq
échecs très bons arbitres ont un mac
mais nain pour un math de maths du
couloir donc un thématiques avec le kg 4
qui le contrôlent les cases et je devais
de le plonger 2 qui bloque le roi donc
le roi s'est enfermé et puis avec la
tour ici on attaquera les trois autres
casta sereine at effectivement donc la
tuant projet qui a été forcée mais y'a
pas le choix en fait avec ses chiens
enfin aussi a forcé son adversaire à
prendre le cavalier finalement ya où il
ya et nuls déjà un minimum
en fait il y avait tout minimum ouais tu
auras bon on va on va commenter ça c'est
assez on commande pas pour l'intérêt
dans cette position là puisque les noirs
peuvent faire mieux mais tout simplement
par le fait que c'est une mule
thématiques
donc c'est un échec perpétuelle que les
noirs peuvent faire avec la dame qui
enferme le roi donc d'un match 4 chef
leroy leurs revenus en vient on fait ch
est donc en fait on fait un petit quart
de tour leroy remonte on refait échec et
on va peut-être les coûts ainsi passé le
pion aux jets d'eau qui bloque le roi
qui se baladent sur ces deux gaz et la
dame qui se baladent sur ces deux cases
là et on répète les coups comme ça c'est
symétrique et ses échecs perpétuelle
donc ça peut vous sauver dans certaines
parties peut y avoir des sept fils avec
esquibien section connais le thème on
peut le calculer très longtemps à
l'avancé
tout à fait donc c'est pour ça que c'est
important se familiariser avec ce genre
de thème le qui peuvent arriver
pur projet quatre bons la menace alors
on la connaît non là mais âgées non
rationnel g3 suivi du mat
donc l'état qui veut simplement se
donner un dernier petit f2 si j'ai trop
si g3 wave et si j'ai trois ça ne marche
pas non maintenant il permet alors c'est
carrément guerrier réalité un trio f7
deux possibilités on échec au roi les
qualifs échec soit comprend qu'elle est
liée avec la tour soit le roi de manger
vite alors on va regarder la première
qui avait plus tard en échec là bas
dames 1 tout au fond à 8
donc on voit que les noirs peuvent
interposés des pièces pour green line of
tout donné et tout de sauver la dame à
la dame et les deux tours alors comme
des beats dame prend effectivement de
l'être il fonde la tour d'hommes mais là
on donne notre tour mais c'était à
chaque fois les marocains c'est sans
issue
ouais voilà c'est les meilleurs coups
c'est ce qui retarde le christ le mat
mais là
des coûts d'ordinateurs ya plus rien à
donner donc ça y est elle avait manqué
sept
noctua nf cet échec si la tour prends ma
du couloir moi j'ai eu ici roi j'ai vite
et chez le noble a facilité les chèques
doublant h6 donc quand on est chef
double ça veut dire qu'il ya deux pièces
qu'ils donnent simultanément voilà donc
le roi est obligé de bouger dans
toujours gagner l'un des feuilletons oui
puisqu'on peut pas prendre deux pièces
en or voilà autant on peut attaquer le
roi avec de presse que le temps parle et
découvert que mohamoud jagger
connaissait englobera mais c'est pas
c'est pas légale en tout cas c'est pas
légal roy a ensuite forcé les nanos plat
on peut se dire on fait nul mais non il
ya la thématique fait tout le nain
faites vous les mains donc ça c'est le
nom des exercices dans une revue des
chèques des mots j'ai vite échec
le roi ne peut pas prendre la dame
puisqu'elle est défendue par le cavalier
c'est la tour qui prend de manière
forcée et là on a en fait on a donné la
dame mais on aime le rendement dans un
cercueil de pièces amis qui fait qu'il
peut plus bouger en lui assène le mat
dit elle étouffe et voilà la mentalité
fait maths à l'étouffée puis c'est
vraiment l'année d'ailleurs cessé ses
parents oui c'est vrai que c'est assez
bien trouver un truc donc ici après qui
avait dit aux cinq ya un piège si les
noirs jouent le coup g3 est bien lié
avec à vie et sept avec soin le mât du
couloir soit le matin à l'étouffée au
choix mais bon schirrhoffen a vu plus
loin il fait damev deux échecs
d'abord le roi montant h12 montrent
enfin oui donc le fisc de vente annotée
webo sur rouages de diabète ou rage 3
matin tout simplement puisque l'option
g2 aurait été cloué au rachat donc forcé
et là c'est l'heure de g3 voilà donc le
maître du couloir qui va être assez dur
le mâle de couleur en vain à noter quand
même que la dame f2 est venu contrôler
un cas de cette malade ce qui fait qu'il
ya plus donc cette mauvaise surprise qui
arrive cet échec
voilà un endroit donné disons le seul
coup ça serait camille f3 kalyev 3 dans
cette version
tourner importe laquelle
on peut ce qu'on peut jouer jolie
peut-être leur chagrin on peut joli joli
elle était sûr que non ça ne marche pas
alors ça ne marche
c'est justement ces jolies puisque là on
peut se dire après tout reprendre d'un
prompt qui avait dû prendre
et là on assène le mât du couloir et
donc ça c'est joli ça c'est joli mais en
fait dans cette position ça marche pas
puisque les blancs sont pas obligés de
prendre la barre et ils peuvent lui qui
rédige et ajoute ériger un bon ça
dominicaine
probablement puisque le projet de mater
sur cette rangée la banque aussi ma
terre celle là un fait c'est pas sur axa
gagne non parce que le ménach sais pas
s'il va signer les purs les pions vont
vite le plan c'est bon c'est en tout cas
ce serait un peu joué avec le feu en
tout cas on n'a pas besoin de ça donc
c'est sûr qu'à liège 3 on peut jouer
devant m moi je pense que pour un f3
menace des mets fins menace de mettre le
maillot couleur comme ça et scipion
prend si on prend non dommage de mazzah
match de mal classés c'est bien aussi de
matmata en un coup donc voilà le baiser
de la mort
tu essayes d'une matante moi j'ai vu le
lancement de france et c'était bien
aussi
donc voilà donc belle victoire avec dans
cette troisième partie le match est donc
le score et d'un ennemi partout après
cette brillante attaque donc bon c'est
quand même les deux joueurs étaient
d'accord pour faire une belle partie on
peut ou on arrive à 50 quand je vous dis
semi rapide je crois que n'importe qui
tout le monde est d'accord pour faire
des belles parties bon c'est à dire que
c'est un peu embêtant d'être le punching
ball
stein et il a dû cesser sa peuvent être
sans connaître de se faire taper dessus
comme ça vous va si on a fait une belle
partie bon on marque comme un camp dit
un proverbe faut être deux pour faire
une belle partie donc ouais mais bon
c'est dommage d'être des drogues douces
football comme là c'est juste le petit
problème alors peu vexant maintenant on
va montrer bon alors décidément pas de
chance pour adeline stein on va montrer
la partie suivante du match mais un
juste un fragment
c'est cette position cette partie là on
va aller directement vers la fin
puisqu'il ya une séquence très amusante
qui montre bien alors les styles
respectifs des deux joueurs
c'est assez excellent il ya donc c'est
par ici
dans cette position là ça dure pendant
très longtemps
c'est un harcèlement de roi alors c'est
tout à fait excellent je suis policière
à bernabeu après on va dire
donc il ya déjà eu des conflits on n'a
pas choisi de commenter cette partie
parce qu'elle est lé 1 comment table
tout simplement laurent je sais pas
gérer rapidement je ne sais pas j'ai vu
que les blancs avaient une petite
initiative mais plus en plus partie
extrêmement compliquée avec une chaîne
a3 des ressources de défense
ingénieuse et complètement improbable
finalement il arrive presque à s'en
sortir puisque dans la position que vous
avez à l'écran il ya égalité matérielle
ces rencontres il entre trois ans on
peut encore compter si tu veux y at-il
entre 3 voilà aouini alors il ya un
point de plus pour les noirs et à faire
de ce soit un homme bon et qui va très
vite at récupérer mais enfin et là
prendre 3 donc avantages matériels pour
einstein foot qu'on leur oppose et donc
ça ça joue puisque on dit que les
footballeurs opposé à venir les nains
mais là c'est pas tout à fait une finale
donc c'est encore effectivement laurent
ça favorise la tacc et c'est ce que
seront ses vicaires enfin papa l'a taxé
initiative disant oui c'est juste
qu'elle a dit aux quatre joué par shirov
donc attaque là tout en question
paraissait logique donc ça arrive ça va
arriver à égalité matérielle toif 4 et
prend ces cinq là il ya égalité
matérielle et en sa personne laurent
eyquem un petit peu
un petit peu mal à l'aise mais bon ça va
être sur le thème de la fourchette 700
deux parties d'accord donc tout de suite
une menace fourchette donc il y aussi ce
qu'ils attaquent le roi est l'atout
gagnant la tour on sait pas trop comment
comment parer ça on voit pas trop de
cases intéressante pour la tour d'autant
plus qu'il ya des problèmes qui
surgissent dans tous les coins par
exemple après tour c4 donc mais dont la
tour sur une case
mais ça ne marche pas et qu'elle y aussi
ces chèques pour cette force et déjà
gager que la découverte donc ici c'est
une première variante les noirs savent
pas trop quoi faire mes gars chine a
remarqué un motif géométrique assez
amusant toutes ces pièces sont sur cases
noires mais ce qui lui permet donc de
mettre le roi en hausse est donc ou que
le fou aïe ça me prend aucun des chacals
et découvertes
mais comme le fou reste malheureusement
sur case blanche est obligé c'est le
foot case blanche il peut pas changer de
couleur et et bien il peut pas aller
prendre des pièces rares alors donc le
fou voilà donc ya pas de soucie pas des
chats qu'elle a découvertes qui sont
douala chef continue
il joue cavalier au cices d'alice et de
mettre un bébé pleure c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de temps mais bon c'est à ses
impressions enfin bon on va voir
problème pour retrouver des cases pour
la tour a noté que si elle va sur des
cases blanches
oui et 20h30 il va y avoir des effets
que la découverte propre possible
notamment la case au cap 6 on continue
mes clients qu'elle et g5 donc la chaire
en fait ne menace rien a priori une avec
force mais les noirs savent pas trop
quoi faire puisque des jeux ils peuvent
se mettre sur une case blanche et il ya
toujours cet échec n'a rien c'est très
rapide c'est selon l'opposition est
vraiment si le cauchemar mais des ouais
c'est terrible c'est la faute et il est
très proche mais fou des 4 donc là il se
mouille pas il joue un coup de fouet le
fou et en sueur case noire ne sera pas
pris part fou de cases blanches et
noires très bien joué évidemment dwayne
surtout ne pas faire de menaces quand on
est en crise d'autant oui c'est à dire
que pour l'adversaire c'est très
stressant et les bonheurs plus forte que
son exécution donc et valeo 4 qui va
arriver et certainement bientôt si on le
laisse
laisse planer on laisse dans le vent
tour des 6es de gâches ta note a cofondé
cette foulée cinq échecs dans la course
à l'euro ne peut pas les en m6 à cause
selon la fourche à il peut pas les en
dés 8 non plus à cause de fourchette
gens qu'il va lire une fuite
c'est très bel et bien en général
d'andorre ce genre de c'est assez
agréable d'avoir un confort c'est comme
ça aux constances pose pas de question
et donc en mai le coup templiers ou même
si on est perdu pas besoin de calculer
on joue beaucoup et puis voilà tous les
autres droits étant évidemment père d'an
phu c4 donc avec ses chiens qui
continuent à mouliner voilà ce que la
bon toujours pas spécialement de menaces
directes enfin quoique sa menace de se
profiler
par exemple qui est venu au 6 mai
fourchette en fait c est 1 6 ghz tout de
suite oui que les gens espèrent qu'il
existait entre eux rapidement oui
puisque après 3,8 qui a foulé cinq
matches oui non wilkie 6 x 3 donc on
enlève le fou de cette pièce des 4 as
d'ailleurs c'est la partie qui avait dit
aussi mais là c'est fini c'est 3,8
forcer les chèques foulée cinq échelons
la callas une pièce louée en général
comme ça c'est pas qu'elle et ses six
mois mais c'est pas terminé en fait
puisque la casse couvriront peut pas
vraiment trop en profiter a noté que
tuer les blancs qui est quand même en
prise pour le moment
dès qu'on fait un échec le cavalier noir
reste des clous et puis on peut pas
l'attaquer pour l'instant ce qui va lier
donc pas de problème ou c4 d'ailleurs à
gagner la connex et chef des clous non
mais en fait ça dure très longtemps
il ya un échange de coups un échange de
frappes tactique et de petites astuces
et qui durent très longtemps qu'elle
écarte donc les devants évidemment
cherche les échanges en asie en plein
échange de cavaliers c'est nul si les
diapos oui et c'est cet échec avec ces
chiffres téva d'accord y'a des
casse-pieds j'ai pour le roi noir donc
qui peut coller en gros et au palais sur
la deuxième rangée wimille obligés
d'aller sur un premier temps voilà
réussit bien aux 7 et 17 et tv5 et
chaque celui qui prend tour des six qui
défend la tour 17
donc ça ne va pas roi des mythes qui a
aidé 5
le cadet de chez rough qui donc 5e et
magique il n'arrête pas de bouger
partout il gesticule dans tous les coins
mais là il est sur une très belle 4,6 à
contrôler sa contrôle plein de gaz très
intéressant simca centrale c'est une clé
à québec à centrale contrôle quand on
est à n'importe quelle pièce quand on
additionne caisse centrale c'est là où
où on atteint le maximum d'activités
voyez plus en plus leur contrôle des
castrats du roi en plus on attaque le
fou c'est très efficace fou j'ai 5 f caf
alors ça c'est bien jouer nos matches
potter ça fait participer un pion à
l'attaqué cette décade le fou ça va le
mettre sur une case où il a pas
spécialement ils ont le fou g5 est assez
stable là donc c'est vrai que c'est bien
de qui choisissent sadeghi flash 4 ça il
a choisi des tours g7 nos menaces rien a
priori mais toujours on sait jamais s'il
ya une menace ou s'il y en a pas c'est
ça qui est curieux dans cette position
qu'edf cinq tours j'ai vite échec 3 17
on a l'impression qu'à d une chaîne est
très proche de s'en sortir est
systématiquement et devant la scène et
rubino innovant que noir temps et
toujours les deux mois il s'est
tellement précis ajoute pour les
blanches bref trois alexei shirov c'est
beau ce qui fait il amène la dernière
pièce en jeu il menait alors c'est même
assez normal c'est normal mais c'est
surtout la menace était tout reprend
cavaliers avec camille autres aux échecs
c'est pas un réflexe qu'on a
systématiquement d'aller monter droit
quand il ya encore beaucoup de pièces
comme ça c'est pas frémir s'est enfin
réveillé donc il doit bouger sans rien
autant la tant attendue
bref trois cahiers des quatre échecs re4
n'attaque lecavalier et la promotion la
faute décisive
la gaine la cagade cavaliers ou 6 il a
fini par craquer à noter que f2 et
c'était reparti je pense pour encore de
nombreux coups à vis et dans tous les
sens et donc la position a l'air
complètement nul mais en fait les ailes
est jouable à l'infini c'est
des trucs assez sympathique dans les
échecs quand même c'est surtout pour les
blancs sur cette puissance en dix ans
pour les noirs en plus quand on perd ce
genre de partie c'est un peu dur alors
on va expliquer la cagade quand même mes
cavaliers au cices c'était la case du
roi c'est à dire que pendant très
longtemps sur l'achat qui serait venu
sur ces crimes maintenant qu'il ne l'a
plus eh bien il ya foule et cinq échecs
donc là on voit que les pièces blanches
en font un travail fantastique
le cavalier contre le c7 et e7 le fou
qui contrôlent donc ces 6 et 17 et la
tour qui contrôle de 8 8 s'est vite un
tour c'est cissé après donc là le roi
est enfermé donc pour ces six français
qui achève et l'a donc la tour et cloud
et c'est terminé on ne doit jamais mis
les pieds secouer un peu ce très
important
voyons comment règles faut jamais
prendre les pièces cloud et donc le
voilà je suis en off connais cette règle
en tant que voilà donc il faut attendre
que l'adversaire se des clous pour
prendre la pièce moi et c'est à dire
qu'on gagne du temps en fait donc voilà
donc belle transformation de shirov
enfin à noter comme qu'il ya une belle
défense danial chaîne parce que c'est
pas évident les garçons sont proches à
tout moment enfin fini en bas mais aussi
skis par équipe à terre lui aussi c'est
la cagade effectivement donc finalement
chirurgienne les deux dernière partie et
s'impose dans ce match je pense que
quelqu'un comme l'écho par exemple
aurait tenu assez facilement franck il a
fait ça je crois qu'il est j'ai discuté
avec beaucoup de grands maîtres qui
m'ont qui m'ont dit qu'ils pensaient que
en fait l'écho était le meilleur joueur
du monde
bien sûr il ya et karpov avant mais
maintenant c'est ça doit devenir joueur
du monde en défense et en défense aux
diagrammes nico c'est quand même oui à
kramnik mais bon les co est vraiment
quand on regarde c'est parti on était
assez impressionné cramique est plutôt
quand même il aime bien l'initiative
on va parler un peu de l'actualité
internationale et française l'auront
puisqu'il ya deux tournois qui arrivent
il ya le premier tournoi c'est le
roumain français cappelle la grande que
tu vas jouer que je dans l'enfer n'est
qu'à peine l'enfer de cap alors on dit
on pourquoi est ce qu'on dit l'enfer de
capèle c'est parce que c'est un énorme
open où il ya énormément de joueurs
soviétique avec des petits classement
qui arrivent il sent très très fort et
très pointu
donc faut aller dans ce tournoi pour
pour jouer comme des bons joueurs moi
j'y vais parce que ça fait assez
longtemps que j'ai pas besoin d'un
tournoi partie langue donc voilà pour
jeu comme des bons joueurs juste pour
entraîner sans aucune autre très relax
donc rappelons que comme 2581 points et
nous tu veux être dans les cinq ou six
meilleurs de se tourner ma page 3 je
veux être 18/10 ccs des doyennes il ya
une centaine de titres et donc c'est
assez impressionnant oui c'est ça y est
toujours plus de 100 grands maîtres 650
joueurs 300 joueurs internationaux
c'est un des plus beaux open français
donc open cessé depuis ses plus belles
au peuple français il sait faire c'est
que oui et puis forme de loin à l'est
c'est un des meilleurs surtout du monde
l'a carrément pour le coup puisque c'est
vraiment extrêmement fort
actualité très importante il ya
également le tournoi de linares qui
arrive est donc dès la semaine prochaine
on fera une émission spéciale dessus
avec commentaires des deux premières
rondes donc jacques à bidias sera notre
invité la semaine prochaine donc six
joueurs un très très beau tournoi on
linares c'est très connu
ça fait dix ans que ça existe ou
peut-être même 15 cette année
petit bémol il y aura ni krainik ni à
nantes
donc je vais donner la liste des joueurs
et tu vas me donner une analyse en fait
après chaque joueur donc on commence par
kaspar en grand favori
voilà j'espère en grand favori c'est
clair karpov un peu vieux pour ce genre
de tournois live in voilà karpov has
been donc bon c'est vrai peter les
coraux peter l'écho plusieurs il va
finir à plus 1 je pense un peu plus de
50% un peu plus de 50% est ce que tu
penses qu'il va perdre des parties
puissent faire l'écho oui mais une vie
dans une partie perdue de parties
gagnées une partie perdue de parties
gagnées donc la formule à linares on la
rappelle il ya six joueurs donc ça fait
cinq adversaires pour chacun et ils se
rencontrent deux fois c'est un double au
real ça fait 10 appareils en tout donc
peter l'écho +18 donc donc en fait ce
que tu veux dire c'est [ __ ] les
consolident les gens retirent les qu il
est pas là pour ne pas perdre alexei
shirov alexei shirov
deuxième comme challenger oui c'est
clair arrive je pense qu'elle fait en
deuxième démarque à ce point je pense qu
espéré shearer soquem est largement
utilisé alors après on retrouve
quelqu'un que tu connais bien puisque tu
as rencontré plusieurs fois il est jeune
il doit avoir à peu près ton âge
peut-être même plus jeunes c'est
alexander great chioukhs et il m'aide à
faire ses preuves
on va voir même un bon examen pour moi
je sais pas ce qui va des je sais pas
quoi penser je sais pas ce qu'il va
faire mais je sais pas et je ne connais
pas vraiment son niveau je n'arrive pas
à voir
alors il a fait quelque chose est soigné
au champion du monde mais bon moi j'ai
prêté moi je conduis évidemment il n'a
pas été très impressionnant mais bon il
choqué mais il joue pas mal mais je sais
pas il a beaucoup d'éloquence je trouve
pour il arrivé très vite très vite très
haut et je sais pas je trouve ça file et
demain il doit faire ses preuves demi
finaliste des championnats du monde
raconte semi rapide et il a eu des
matches et alves qui paye 20 choo qui
joue contre un geste après donc bon
alors là c'est la loterie du charles
gagnon d'accord mais il faut quand même
avoir les nerfs solides
un bon niveau et je crois que c'est
avoir les nerfs plus solides que lui je
pense que c'est assez assez dur ça c'est
dur donc nerfs très solides fait but
est-ce que tu le vois créé la surprise
dans ce tournoi puisque c'est vrai qu'on
maintenant j'en ai fait partie des
outsiders comme nom moi chopin unis va
souffrir ces plaintes au rang de ce
niveau avec les coaches ont fait
kasparov
je crois qu'ils vont le voir même karpov
et ils vont le voir arriver il faut se
préparer
il n'y a pas encore assez d'expérience
faut qu'ils apprennent d'abord dansé
dansé dans tournant ainsi peu bond le
dernier joueur quand même qui est une
joueuse
il s'agit de judit polgar que je connais
bien aussi ben ouais j'ai dit pour les
achètent pas je pense qu'elle va
s'offrir une wii donc le pronostic de
placement dans son hall ans
donc disons kasparov shirov l'écho
karpov
paul gray two vers la faune politique ex
aequo à la dernière place d'accords
balorre donc de toutes façons la semaine
prochaine eh bien on aura un aperçu de
ce début de tournoi avec les deux
premières rondes qui auront été joués
donc on verra si tes pronostics se
confirment on rappelle que tes
pronostics et à nantes 2e avec kenzy qui
attendent avant la fin alors qu'il était
à ce moment là 5e ou 6e du classement y
voit là et avait eu raison donc laurent
très bon pronostiqueur donc on te
remercie en tout cas de bon pour
l'analyse et pour les pronostics et puis
on a bientôt dans une prochaine édition
de garde c'est à toi de barbarie